how's it going red
my eye look at this hat this hat is
amazing
welcome back to limb we get shot by this
crab seaman and for whatever reason then
turns us into a zombie I don't really
get what's up with it I can only turn
left I can't turn left and right
I can only like run faster and [ __ ] like
that jump those mmm they want it so I'm
thinking that I should push the box yeah
it's gonna turn here yeah I gotta push
you come on Jared we can do this push it
all right all right nice and easy nice
and easy no need to rush it there we go
and then no did it take yeah Jania spear
strikes again all right
it's weird I don't think of these things
right away when you play for a while but
when you take a break and come back it
gets smarting look so far I haven't done
a single time in this episode and that's
about to change real soon
what is this don't piss me off hi I
don't need you stupid wheel got a toad
they're kind of gross all right don't
kill me all right he wants the mushrooms
come on you little [ __ ] fine gonna
jump over there yep if I jump here tank
dumb eat that shot trap he's smarter
than your legs he's smarter than
anything all right
boom shocka truck no I didn't trap him
all right let's try that again
[ __ ] you come in stupid [ __ ] what are
you gonna do what you gonna do when he's
gonna get trapped in the machinery come
here you little [ __ ]
come here stupid-ass hahahaha you
strapped in the hamster wheel
good job froggy frog frog is a bro who
would have died you know
there we go that starts the machinery
whatever the hell that does it does not
look good
[ __ ] don't kill me it's it's a rain
machine okay
Thank You froggy I'll come back to you
don't lean back Harry
I don't stupid frog think I care
Jerry needs to save his sister he
doesn't that time with this [ __ ]
zero deaths just want to point that out
there all right what do we got here all
right
am I gonna die here No
left frame I'm gonna oh we needed to be
filled with more water and then we can
pass we have to wait for this no I had
to fix it
ah
can I go back
with you lug alone to get back to moon
see I'm pretty smart today
all you told me I had to do it well you
probably cheap
come on Jerry this is not the time for
funsies all right log oh I know it goes
down ah oh no Sonic No
silly
why did I do it so early I'm so spiffing
settin up and cause for the veggies I've
got to be free tonight
but I'm the captain all right one death
that's pretty right oh no please don't
be a spider please no spider what do we
got
okay this looks dangerous haha good job
Larry Jerry whatever the [ __ ] alright
let's jump over it there we go I did it
I'm a genius I wonder what kind of
radiation he was exposed to when he got
those eyes or whatever
I can't Brown here take you with us cuz
why not I thought people said this game
was really difficult maybe it gets more
difficult than ventually but so far it's
no puzzle that's really been like that
challenging right hey I'm not
complaining
I don't like challenging puzzles now
what is this do what I don't want to
drown Oh perfect we needs a ladder
I saw the Saturn why do I keep singing
[ __ ] old songs I'm sorry go Larry
oh [ __ ] we need to hurry here wanted to
pull this before we died we died for
poor Gary
haha define and it open up my eyes
that's a sign I'm dead oh I get it now I
see it
there we go
my bad my bad there we go
go Larry Jerry sorry I keep messing up
your name Chuck baronet shut up you
sound like a girl
alright I don't know why that was so
[ __ ] difficult for me uh uh we're
gonna die
he doesn't seem to give a [ __ ] I think
Jerry's like type of person who don't
really care
ah poor box poor boy I love you box
don't break don't break my BA oh it's
still coming
see you box me again oh [ __ ] this is not
good this is that is [ __ ] terrible
[ __ ] me
alright there we go
hopefully we're done with this water
drama where jump [ __ ] haha water ain't
got [ __ ] on me [ __ ] ain't got [ __ ] on
me come up here you little [ __ ]
[ __ ] water work puzzles I kind of
miss a spider it was like exciting and
[ __ ] what is this I'm probably gonna
stand here I got both [ __ ] their ball
are you [ __ ] with me
ball you better not be [ __ ] with me
ah bah what are you doing oh I'm
supposed to have the ball there [ __ ]
well I might as well kill myself I'd say
it was a [ __ ] ball I hate my life I
know Lisa Lowen like that like this just
oh I have to like Taemin
I can only hope that it will go to the
left but it's not gonna I might as well
kill myself oh come here you little
[ __ ]
waah push it to the lemon walk along the
razor's do you better go down ball
oh you disappoint me so much come on
ball please please I love you ball
please go a little left why didn't you
do it ball [ __ ] me kill yourself
come on yes
you're letting my domain now a BH I push
you till done run Larry
Jerry whatever Lindsay [ __ ] go what is
that
there we go finalmente Jesus Christ I
always make the easiest things difficult
I don't know why I tell you why because
you can't finish it sorry I don't know
what's up with this thing you like my
singing well I keep telling people to
sign my contract of singing this but no
one ever won do it it's only Larry and I
mean oh that's beautiful
thumbnail all right
what do we got here oh let's touch this
she should do things now why did I do
that why did I do that I regret that I
regret this this session
jump badge okay wasn't that bad ah good
job Larry good job I'm not dying that
much I don't know what's up with that
well I'm still dying today
can I move it now is that the thing this
thing is pretty [ __ ] steady I can't
make that jump but if I am dear now okay
that helps that helps a little bit
don't you think ladder low I don't know
about me but I don't I love you Larry
have I ever told you that no no yes no
yes no yes no yes
now
flow to me baby bear this is not good
can I make this jump I don't thinks that
no I doesn't make it different oh I can
do it all right
Wow and the Resta mated you Larry watch
out for the crab semen Larry I keep
telling you Larry three six six oh no
not crab semen
[ __ ] you crab semen oh come on Larry
crab seminar isn't that bad not that
I've ever tried it is ah crab semen no
what am i [ __ ] crime semen man all
right here's the plan
shoot me ah no why did you Larry
disappoint me no why Ari I hate you now
you're not cool man all right I just had
to wait for it to dangle
that's what she said hahaha hilarious
all right now crab semen can't stop me
you're gonna have to aah what are you
what where are you go it's gonna turn
its got time yes beautiful I don't know
how this makes sense but we're doing it
but what but what don't win it
I hope the background doesn't kill me
don't you dare kill me background all
right I think I'll jump over hey oh that
looks scary
it's down here I think I'll go down here
for now
no I refuse to die I came so far to lose
it all alright you need to hurry right
go that real oh I love you okay not
really
all right now what what was this good
for I need to take the box or something
like that
this is multi difficult ax oh no Larry
what all we have to take the box back I
get it I get it down all right no we're
not gonna make it are we gonna make it
we can do it I can believe in you Larry
we came so far [ __ ] me [ __ ] you all
right push it push it push it real good
well what the [ __ ] do we do now no Larry
what is your plan here what how's that
supposed it doesn't even [ __ ] float
what's the point huh what are you doing
here why didn't you tell me before where
the hell did you come up no not a waiter
job I'm so bad
[ __ ] yo Larry [ __ ] all of y'all all
right I think we have to wait longer
than I actually think aah
daddy why did you okay eat that thank
you
[ __ ] crabs man mess up my day we're
going up here now why I don't know all
right what are we going where's some
jump oh I was happy
beautiful I'll replay that in slow-mo
did you like it
no well you can't like everything where
grab it
No all right where the hell are we now
Can I grab this maybe
yep no no please please ah all right
what the hell do we do now Oh oh [ __ ]
we're at the hotel
what the [ __ ] all right press I think
that's all the time I had for today
that's always a lot of fun to play this
game actually enjoying a lot who ever
would have thought PewDiePie can play